I am back
the assassination assassinato
it's also weird
gotta remind myself I'm in beer this
looks cool
does not want to kill
me
Into the Woods
[Music]
that's how you make it less creepy all
right here we are
wow
okay this is creepy what's happening oh
ah
apex predator come for his friend
oh
my tiny I'm tiny I'm standing up I'm a
big boy oh I'm crouching here we go
confirmed kill
dang it he's dead earpiece
[Music]
okay our client considers Agent 47 and
Olivia Hall as a serious threat you
can't underestimate them I never do Joe
oh [ __ ] someone saw me he saw me hey
don't listen to him me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys
it's me
PewDiePie
I had a guy I'll just walk through thank
you very much people love me here what's
up bro shoot him
let's try that again oh God I gotta
blend in at the party
hey how you doing
that's good what's up everyone it's me
pottyboy45 I love techno music so
[Music]
that's a crazy Swedish guy oh this is a
crazy Swedish
how do I blame him in Germans hello
[Music]
Oh I thought you were going for a
handshake sorry sorry about that hey
what's up uh it's okay
let's try this again how's it going
everyone it's me okay
you know me definitely not true here
why can't I be here am I not cool I'm
not cool enough I'm not cool enough
I'm not [ __ ] quiet
how do I gotta disguise as a party guy
hello
come on
this is my height
about me
help me oh we're just chilling here
right can I have some water
huh it's a super uncomfortable stuff I'm
standing alive
excuse me
there we go what's up guys
laughs
I like your hair very cool hey hey hey
these are my friends
hey back on that's right we do the thing
thank you
for I'm going in yes
[Applause]
get frisked
sorry about this moment
this is this is what we're doing
Sweden back in the day
oh God
you can joined twins that's awesome
hold up I'll fix it for you
look at things
what's up girl oh God stop that oh she's
smoking without a cigarette
yeah I've been to a lot of places like
that I've been to I actually been to two
parties at one party before
no big deal
[Music]
what are you gonna do buddy what are you
gonna do about it nice cheese
nice hey where you get it from the hat
store
that's what I thought
yeah this is kind of thick there's so
many people
ah
excuse me excuse me excuse me
you're not on drugs are you excuse me
hello where are you going
[Music]
she drank too much
she fell no no no she fell I saw it uh
she had some Banana Shoes how do they
know it's me I haven't done anything the
game say push I push before we continue
quick word from sponsor it's spring
refresh yourself with g-fuel buy one get
one sale this is a huge opportunity to
stock up on some Jeep fuel they have a
new flavor out called generic
marshmallow birds with the flavor
profile of candy coated marshmallow like
peeps
if you don't know G fuel it's the
greatest energy drink of all time it's
economical especially if you get the
burger it's convenient it's got the most
flavors out of anyone I've seen and
they're all so goddamn good however
I am the proud owner of the two greatest
drinks on the Planet yusu slash a
wonderfully lemony pineapple flavor
peace Japan and of course PewDiePie
flavor the greatest flavor of all time
no one has ever said they don't like it
because they they would be lying I drink
this for breakfast I guess it's so good
bogus sound basically means you can pick
almost any tub for example use of flavor
and then you can pick another one same
one if you want and you get one for free
it's a great way to support your
favorite creators because you I am your
favorite Creator
[Music]
oh no code needed just use the link in
description guys I would recommend the
generic marshmallow Birds the new one oh
the Swedish Fish one is really good oh
bubble gum is good too there's a ton of
great flavors there Sonic's pizza ring
is really [ __ ] good too
they're all good check them out that's
the point of GPU use the link in
description stock up and thanks for
watching and event blend in as Club
guests
stop blending in I can't stop blending
in this is who I am what are you
okay wait what if I do this
[Music]
blending in
I've been here all along yeah well
what
I can't believe this
foreign
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ER we dump
okay I'm bartender I'm blending in I'm a
bartender and I'm playing it what's up
home oh
yeah be polite
yeah
hey hey limbo oh damn you're good at
that oh [ __ ] too hard everyone's such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's like he touched them
and they call the cops
welcome back Felix it's time to go
okay I gotta sneak past these guys
luckily I didn't raise any suspicions
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
she's immune
yes
drop the weapon
I don't think so
man banana lost like power hold up hey
bro you want a banana
thank you
oh Jesus what's wrong with them
looking good man
sorry sir
what if I give you this banana will that
change your mind
yeah
all this banana here
you don't want them all right we don't
want it got it hey
stop smoking
stop smoking
sleeper it's dangerous
stop it
stop it stop it now I don't even stop it
she wouldn't listen and look what
happened
what's up officer
tell you what I'm a biker smell it
what do you think
it was bananas hey what's that it was it
was
sorry banana someone had to take the
blame wait there's a whole outdoor area
oh my God that's kind of awesome
oh there's my targets
okay okay we got to finish this
why is no one scared I thought I was
super oh
why am I the least threatening person
I'm never partying again